there's TV show got canceled but but
Discovery gives them a whole network
discovery's like yo we're going to make
the Magnolia Network all around you guys
and you guys are going to create like
hundreds of hours of like TV that's
Fixer-Upper content cooking content
gardening content like all the like
house [__] right and now they've built
this Empire the the kind of the bottom
line of the the headline of the story is
this couple in a in a span of about 10
years has built a billion dollar brand
around themselves so it's that big it's
that big
[Music]
laughs
all right
I hope they keep in what just happened
so before we hit record it's like five
four three two one and Sam on three
takes out a drink out of nowhere at
three seconds left and just chugs it
like tilts up not only just tilt it up
squeezes the bottle like it's a it's a
Kool-Aid or like a Capri Sun or
something and these trucks some
carbonated drink and then it goes to one
and then he puts up the one symbol like
hold on look to the side burps flexes
re-centers himself and is ready for the
bypass that was Elite that was an elite
preps for a podcast
dude I'm on top of it I drank so many
beverages in uh we had this Fast Company
article written about uh the Hampton
lunch and the reporter in like the first
paragraph called about how I left the
interview to grab a root beer and I came
back
yeah he skimmed the foam off the root
beer like it was a Guinness
and then finished it
held up the one second sign to my lips
tell me to shush as he uh as he drained
during the interview you know how men
drink like ipas that crap and then they
look at the class after they take a
drink and try to analyze it that's
basically what I do with my Coke Zero
dude you should you gotta have more
weird quirks because like you can't
really be a billionaire founder if
you're not super weird so you know you
got to start picking up some things like
you know oh he only wears you know uh
open-toed sandals with socks and like
you know he wears uh shorts with you
know EMF protection on his pockets
because he's worried about radiation and
what are the other weird things that you
can do well I had a I had carbonated
water on tap for a while that was pretty
awesome uh like I I like only drink
carbonated water no normal water oh do
you have sleeps during full moons do you
have uh you don't have any
eccentricities do you no that's why I'm
broke dude I need I need some of these
before you know otherwise uh how could I
be how can I be the weird Rich
billionaire I'm trying to be
we have uh Sean and I have these friends
I won't name who they are but they're
they're young guys and the minute that
they got like a mild amount of success
like maybe 500 000 in Revenue they
clearly had read like naval's book on
like charging by time or something like
that and then they sent all of their
clients to client services business
saying we don't do meetings anymore and
uh that they were leading into that
eccentricity thing and I wanted to tell
them you guys are doing great but you're
not there yet and that's the biggest
customer dropped them immediately yeah
it was like oh yeah well we kind of
needed to meet to talk about the I get
okay well I guess we'll just find
another vendor
yeah I want to tell him like it's great
I love the attitude you know showed up
to meetings with the shirt off and it
was just like well that's cool it's one
way it's one way to wear your shirt that
that that's not the way that that
particular client was willing to do it
so it's no longer their client but that
is our way yeah that is definitely they
do have a nipple policy unfortunately
yeah
they're not on board with the free the
nip campaign unfortunately yeah oh we
forgot to shout out we're doing a live
pod April 29th that's a Saturday if you
live in Austin or if you want to fly in
Sean and I along with MFM guest Andrew
Wilkinson are doing a live pod so if you
go to mfmpod.com you'll see the details
and you'll see tickets uh we're gonna do
a lot pod we did this in Vancouver a
couple months ago it's sold out this
one's gonna sell out as well so if
you're interested in hanging out with
Sean me Andrew Wilkinson as well as five
600 other guests and fans of MFM we're
gonna be there so check it out
mfmpod.com and you'll see the the banner
up top where you can check out tickets
um dude we have a bunch of stuff you
have chip and Joanna Gaines on there
today and I went to Waco this weekend
where they are from oh no way and like
saw some of their houses yeah that's
crazy okay so you might know more about
this than I do okay so let me tee it up
and then you tell me what you know about
these people so
here's my my trail of events and uh I'll
put the disclaimer out there right now
if you actually know about them that
this is gonna all sound very Elementary
this is gonna sound very very beginner
because I was a complete beginner about
like who are these people
for their listener though Sean doesn't
know like I I told him what Coldplay was
last week like he didn't know he thought
that was like baseball in the winter
time he didn't know anything about like
pop culture so this is you learning out
loud yeah exactly like uh I still use a
flip phone so I I would I left my house
I go to Target and inside Target there's
this one section that my wife always
goes into and it's the only section in
Target that looks like this where
there's a giant picture of this happy
white couple
and it's their names like it's like oh
here's aisle one two three four five
chip and Joanna Gaines six seven eight
nine say why do they have their own
section so I noticed that first and I
thought hmm that's interesting are these
YouTubers what what is the who are these
people is this the owner of Target what
is this and so I noticed that and filed
that away
then I was talking to aldone who came on
the Pod uh or we talked about it on the
Pod who
runs Missouri Star Quilt Company the big
Quilt Company a huge quilt company and
he did this thing where he started
buying up a section of a town he
basically bought a town and started to
build it out he wanted to make it like
you know quilt heaven so basically a
mecca for where Quilters would go as
like a as a pilgrimage to go and just
like really indulge in their Hobby and
he told me world for grandmas Disney
World for yeah for your auntie so so he
was like all right well
he goes I go does anybody else do this
and he goes well there's there's chip
and Joanna Gaines thing in Waco and I go
there they are again who are these
people
and you know fool me once shame on me
and film me twice shame on me finally
I'll look you up and I looked him up and
they got an incredible story it sounds
like you're pretty familiar with them
but
um he had told me one thing that kind of
like caught my attention he goes it's it
shocks me by the way you don't know
about these people I mean like in the
Midwest and amongst like moms like
you're so California that you don't know
about this they've been in the game for
like 10 years uh but I don't know too
much about them yeah it's you know it's
it's quaint but um I I I I looked him up
they the YouTube videos are amazing by
the way if you if you've watched YouTube
videos so they own a part of town in
Waco that they've just branded as their
own they bought these two abandoned I
think silos like grain silos and so they
called it like whatever siloville or
whatever and they have The Silo abrasion
at the end of the year where it's just
like this is a huge party for themselves
so their brand Magnolia is the like
everywhere in this little area so they
have the Magnolia Market where you go
buy your stuff and then they have their
Magnolia Table Restaurant which is
served by the vegetables from Joanna's
garden and then there's the Magnolia
other thing and then there's a magnolia
other thing and it's just all them and
they get about 2 million visitors a year
just coming and making the pilgrimage to
Waco Texas which is really the middle of
nowhere for Texas I lived in Texas and I
never went to Waco like it was not even
in my top 10 places to go in Texas and
so they have made Waco a destination
they literally have raised the housing
prices in that area by like 24 because
they have made it an attraction and
their story is kind of interesting I
don't know if you know their their
backstory do you know do you know pretty
well I don't so they uh the story goes
something like this and again I'm a
beginner so I'm doing the thing where
you read the press release and you're
like oh that's how they met how how
fortunate or you know like when you hear
about somebody saying like how'd you
think of the idea it's like well I saw a
single mother struggling and I just
decided that that would be my mission
it's like no dude you read a report that
said this Market was growing and that's
why you you know you started this
business but like here's the pr version
of their story uh they live in Waco
Texas chip the guy goes into this uh car
repair shop that her dad owns sees a
picture of her on the wall and decides
I'm gonna marry that girl suspicious but
okay uh keeps going back to the car
repair shop yes that that story it could
it could go a different route it just
totally it's like uh it's like when you
whispered someone's ear like I see you
versus like write it on their mirror
when they're in the shower you know what
I mean like it
text matters here the editing of the
story really makes it a makes it okay
but it could go either way it doesn't
end up in a freezer
um so yeah so he keeps going back and he
eventually bumps into her ask her out on
a date they go on a date uh whatever
they end up getting together this is
back in like 2003-ish and so he was
doing house flipping and she was kind of
like I guess like working with the doing
like commercials for her dad's car car
repair place or whatever and they get
together and they decide um they they
don't have anything to their name
but they decide to try to try to make
something of this house flipping thing
she's like oh I could use my design
sense you're a contractor and let's uh
so they move into this like 800 square
foot house and they renovate it while
they live there end up flipping one
flipping two flipping through they start
to you know successfully flip some
houses and Waco but still no big deal
is that a TV show from HGTV starts
casting and they read about the this
husband and wife house flipper in uh in
Waco Texas they said well wake up we're
kind of hoping for somebody in L.A or
New York or maybe Atlanta or something
like that but like okay whatever let's
go down to Waco and meet him and uh and
he's got this like kind of big
personality he's real outgoing and she's
really good looking and so it like plays
well for TV so they get their show on
HGTV called Fixer-Upper and basically
the show like from day one is a hit and
so they go from
kind of husband and wife Small Time
house flippers like very small houses
that they're flipping in Waco to now on
TV
um and they they're doing this and they
do five or six seasons they become very
famous on on HGTV show gets canceled
but what they did was they had built
this uh this following and they had
built they had this brand in mind that
they're called Magnolia like they had
opened up a retail store back in the day
they closed it because it wasn't really
going so well but they had this idea for
this store called Magnolia so when the
show ends they do two things they reopen
Magnolia as a beautiful place in Waco
and then secondly they go to the the
just the Channel Discovery Channel and
they go and their TV show got canceled
but but Discovery gives them a whole
network discovery's like yo we're gonna
make the Magnolia Network all around you
guys and you guys are going to create
like hundreds of hours of like TV that's
Fixer-Upper content cooking content
gardening content like all the like
house [__] right and now they've built
this Empire the the kind of the bottom
line of the whole the the headline of
the story is this couple in a span of
about 10 years has built a billion
dollar brand around themselves so it's
that big it's that big so there's no
real numbers that like have come out so
like if you go look for their net worth
or their revenue super Hush Hush which
you know
just makes those little hairs on my arms
start to tingle a little bit I know I
know when it's that Hush Hush that that
means it's a lot bigger than you think
especially because you see it like
Target partnered with them to develop
that line of goods in their store so
like when Target it's not even like they
got their brand into Target it's like
Target came to them it's like let's make
a brand that's like a big deal they have
pillars move in silence Killers move in
silence and you hear yeah so if you
don't hear about it if you don't hear
about it in TechCrunch you know it's
doing good I thought you were gonna hit
him with a G's and lasagna type of line
type of no
no not well you know I I think I've uh
I've milked that one dry dude it's like
my mom when she was on the phone with
like a customer service person and here
you're like a as an apple b as in Bob
whatever she goes K is a knife
I just lost it I was like I don't think
you understand how that works
yeah it's like it's hilarious okay so
they they operate like K is a knife
um I grew up on this street called
Simpson and I would be like uh I'd be
like you know my address is this is this
Simpson like O.J Simpson and uh
it works
um anyways their their app that has
their TV show network has like tens of
thousands of reviews on it so that means
that that app is doing pretty well and
that's a paid that's like their own
version of Netflix right like that's
like kind of stunning you never really
see an influencer that has their own
whole subscription Network and so they
have
the cookbooks journals retail stores
brand uh paint brand uh furniture brand
uh they have their TV show Network they
got everything and this idea and they
have their own town which gets two
million visitors a year like if your
website gets two million visitors a year
they're doing pretty okay you're right
you're you're out there let alone two
million people making the pilgrimage to
your small town in Waco to come buy [__]
from your stores that's kind of
impressive I guarantee you that these
people will end up billionaires off of
this Magnolia brand this Magnolia brand
has to be worth High hundreds of
millions if not over a billion dollars
already
have you been to Waco ever no
dude so I went to Waco this weekend
because and I'll tell a quick story then
we'll get back to this but basically uh
last year I I randomly came across this
guy who had this new Airbnb it was
basically a piece of land that he built
a lake on and he puts and he built seven
airbnbs I was so curious I couldn't find
them on social media I call them up
yeah he built a lake like it was like uh
like a plot of land and they built not a
huge like more more a pond is a better
is a better way to describe it but but
it's it's a lake I guess but I call them
up and I go tell me your story goes well
I had a part I was an accountant I had
my own small business for accounting I
just built this Airbnb thing I think
it's going to be really successful but I
really described myself as an artist I
love to paint and play music and right
right away I'm like I'm in do you want
to hang out
start hanging out with them he's part of
this thing I mentioned it called
Homestead Heritage it's this religion
slash Community they it's like all
different parts of Christianity in it
and they believe in like sustainability
and and the weird part is they believe
in craftsmanship so the way that they
like find God Is by like doing things
with their hand and doing doing it well
so anyway this weekend I went and
celebrated Easter at his church and like
they like had a whole same thing around
for a long time or did this it was like
a recently created religion okay
basically the story is is that one of
the the main guy which is his wife's
grandpa I believe uh her the wife's
Isaac's uh wife's grandfather lived in
New York was atheists found God somehow
and felt like the best way to like show
that I love God is to like just be
excellent to everything I do and be kind
to people among other things but that
was basically it for some reason they
moved to Waco they get 500 acres and
they build a whole community on there
and then this guy Isaac now has built
this Airbnb a few miles away and he
tweeted out his profits in his first
year business he did a million in profit
and so I went and I became friends with
them and I went and hung out there and I
drove through all all through Waco and
basically in Waco Waco's sorry Waco
people it's not nice uh it's not it's
not it's it's like objectively like a
fairly run down place as if maybe it was
like an oil Town it feels like there was
once something there and then now it's
not and when you drive through that area
you see like not nice house not nice
house nice house and I told him that and
he goes oh yeah that's the chip in
Joanna's house like they like started
here remodeling homes and you could
distinctly tell which one is their brand
and it's and and so like it's like
basically like Isaac French who like
brings in all these people and Chip and
Joanne like you know way above him but
that's like my understanding of Waco at
the moment
yeah there's these like uh these these
like kind of Simplicity based um
communities or religions or or uh
cultures where it's like like I'm on
their homepage right now it says
Homestay Heritage is an agrarian
craft-based intentional Christian
Community it stresses Simplicity
sustainability self-sufficiency service
and quality craftsmanship and then
there's literally like a video of a cow
eating leaves and then like a boy
stitching a baseball himself
yeah I say I never did
well I was like uh Isaac showed me
around he goes here let me show you the
orchard I planted last week you know and
it's like it has 200 apple trees he's
like we did this for the community
anyone could come take an apple it'll be
ready in like five years and that's what
he does instead of watching TV so if I
like I'll be like hey have you seen this
movie he's like no I don't really watch
movies and I'm planting trees not a
whole lot of my first million podcast
listeners out there probably there were
a few I think there was a few but you
know they're more fans of like Johnny
Appleseed than Sean Perry
yeah you know what I mean like uh
they're they're done like Johnny apples
like posters in their room
yeah but uh and dude when I so I've sold
the story many times I used to work for
Mike Wolf from American Pickers and that
was where I first learned about like
entertainment and business and things
like that but Mike Wolf was American
Pickers at the time was like the second
most popular show on TV when I worked
there number one was Pawn Stars and like
number four was David Letterman like to
give you an idea and and we I know for
real that's the that was the real
rankings and then
I would be at the store and some days we
would sell thirty thousand dollars of
t-shirts at the store and these like
were not nice T-shirts they were just
normal like with the logo on it we would
sell like 10 grand worth of mugs and so
like these shows kill it and what Mike
did was he would film himself basically
the show was he would drive to Barnes
find old stuff tell you the history
about it buy it and then sell it and he
would uh he spent like four years
driving around with a video camera
filming this trying to pitch it and then
when he finally did Pitch it he got the
production rights or I guess he kind of
like what Rob Dyrdek did I think that's
where the money is and it sounds like
that's what Magnolia did too yeah
exactly the the I mean the the breadth
of this Empire is is kind of stunning to
me right it's like
uh whether it's Home Goods it's a
restaurant it's coffee books it's the
it's the uh the bakery it's the TV Show
Network it's the target line it's like
and and their brand is like they're this
relatable
you know Blue Collar you know salt of
the earth people it's like yeah like
they are but they also have some part of
them that's Rupert Murdoch and they're
right they are flexing that Rupert
Murdoch over the last you know 10 years
I wonder if they have like a manager or
if they're just doing this all in
themselves like Rupert Murdoch in
Wrangler jeans you know like it's we're
relatable but we'll gut your heart out
if we had to right if succession was in
denim yeah uh no I dig these I dig these
people the worst thing that would happen
to them is a Johnny K plus eight
remember Johnny K plus eight of course
how can I forget man they were they were
some of the first guys to get popular
like in the reality TV world of TLC and
then they get divorced and it ends
horribly just like Honey Boo Boo man
Honey Boo Boo same thing it always ends
horribly so hopefully it doesn't end
that way I remember like seeing if your
shtick is just how many kids you can
have
that is not gonna have a sustainable
it's like sometimes you see these
YouTubers and they come out real hot
because it's like I'm buried alive with
tarantulas 10 million clicks you're like
yo but where to from here son where are
you gonna go with this like this is not
a sustainable path for you
yeah I uh but I like these people I mean
they seem like pretty like I don't know
wholesome but we'll see how how money
impacts things well you have Oprah on
here and I think that chip and Joanna
gained uh and other people like them
like brene brown they're kind of filling
this Oprah Gap like Oprah left some big
shoes to fill I feel
um and I've been Amazed by by the do you
know do you follow brene Brown very much
yeah my wife is reading all her stuff
and like she's kind of killing it
amongst like the empathy crowd the
vulnerability crowd yeah yeah
we're against those offense who are all
about authenticity yeah the capital E
uh or like if I hear one one more person
say the n-word Nuance
like that's like that that's the thing
man it's Nuance it's empathy
with that joke I was like Sam don't end
it here man we've had a good run but
don't end it here nuance
uh Have You Seen Her Netflix special
no no I I like her but that's not my
speed it's a it's a gotta watch
um it's that good it's that good so go
watch her first Netflix special it's
some you gotta watch it just because
you've never seen anything like it it's
basically
Tony Robbins Oprah and a stand-up
comedian at the same time like she comes
out on stage like a stand-up comedian
and she's funny without telling too many
like jokes like it's not like set up
punchline but she's funny
but then she starts talking about
vulnerability and herself and then
people in the crowd are crying and
you're just like what is hap what kind
of event is this you're it's like you
know twister with my emotions like I
don't know what's going on I got right
leg I'm sad and I got you know left hand
on empowered I didn't know what was
happening it's kind of an incredible
little live show that she's created and
I could at first I was like why would
Netflix give a special to this person I
don't even understand what that could be
but it's actually pretty pretty well
done for what it is and I could see why
she's so likable why she is so like uh
relatable to people
you quickly went from like wow to wow
[Laughter]
uh no I'll I'll watch her do uh do you
want can I tell you a little about Oprah
so we we we're gonna talk about Oprah
last time we didn't really know what we
were talking about so I dug in a little
bit I guess the the theme of this
episode then is uh you know one of the
TV Empires or female TV Empire or
something like that I don't know let's
get let's let's see
uh TV Empires that everyone knows about
that you and I are just discovering 20
years after the fact Empire's with
empathy that the boys discover seven
years after they they were off air
capitalized both those E's uh all right
I'll tell you a little bit about Oprah
so she started at 17 by uh doing beauty
pageants she won Miss Black Tennessee at
age 19. she had her first job at CBS
station in uh Nashville a few years
later she moved to Maryland and uh then
back to Nashville and eventually she was
the first African-American news anchor
uh on TV and that was in Nashville she
basically had an issue where she
struggled to show objectivity because
she couldn't really report the news
because she was showing too much empathy
and she was pretty casual and at the
time like this was like Hey Oprah you
gotta like you know keep it straight you
can't like Express remorse or like show
too many too much emotions like well
Let's uh let's take this a different way
so she created a show called people are
talking and that aired originally in
1977 and she would improvise and she was
casual
kind of like you and I at one point
could say yeah she was like the MFM of
the 70s
um and by the end of the decade so after
like three or four years she was beating
Phil Donahue in the local ratings and
Phil Donahue was God uh so he was like
The Man In Charge So eventually she
keeps doing that for a little while
longer but in 1986 so about 10 years
after starting that she gets her own
show it's called the Oprah Winfrey Show
and she along with a couple outside
investors established her own production
company called Harpo Productions Harpo's
Oprah spelled backwards and at 32 years
old she became the first black woman to
have a nationally syndicated show and
she still owns 80 of that production
company
and all along the the way she started
like innovating innovating so in 1996
she created the uh her uh her book club
which made 130 million in sales in the
year one and arguably set the groundwork
for this like massive influencer
industry that we have then in 98 she
co-founded the oxygen uh Media Group
which has programming towards all types
of uh shows mostly towards women she
launched Oprah Magazine she had a radio
show uh in 2010 the Oprah show ended
after 24 years and she had you know all
the best guests leading up till then
2011 she launched uh OWN Oprah Winfrey
Network and then all along has been
doing all types of stuff so for example
in 2015 she bought 10 stake in Weight
Watchers and then the stock 6X like
within a year or two of that happening
in 2008 she sold most of her uh stake to
of own to Discovery and she's done a ton
of interesting stuff between now and
then but he listened to her Empire so
she has the Oprah Winfrey Show which had
over 20 20 8 000 guests giving away 570
cars had five presidents on
um she got 20 000 fan letters the finale
had 16.4 million views she also owns
Harpo still to this day they've uh
collectively it's done two billion
dollars in profits and made a couple
movies as well including the color
purple beloved and Selma they have 200
employees in Chicago the uh own so the
her network Oprah Winfrey Network uh it
started with a hundred million dollars
in funding eventually she sold most of
the stake but she's still CEO of that
she has Oprah Magazine which in the
first year did 140 million in Revenue
just from subscriptions
and then she has Oprah and friends which
is a uh uh XM radio contract uh or or
show where she got 55 million dollars in
the first three years she's invested in
Weight Watchers True Food kitchens which
is basically a restaurant that has 42
locations she uh helps start a food
science startup backed by Oprah Katy
Perry and a few others that has a
billion dollar in valuation and she also
is a big investor in Oatley then and
this is finally she has a 45 million
dollar estate in California a 14 million
dollar one in Washington in Colorado she
has 60 Acres for 14 million in Hawaii
she has over a thousand acres and she
has uh basically her net worth Grew From
at age 32 she got her first million at
41 340 million 97 at the age of 43 550
million and at the age of 48 she became
a billionaire so that's Oprah's story
um super fascinating I mean she's been
in the game forever it seems and I think
she's what 60 something now and still
killing it I didn't realize she was the
CEO and like active and all this I
thought she was more so like a face but
I think she's actually not you know not
just a face but uh it seems like she's
like actually like a like a mogul a
tycoon right you know what's uh one
thing that stands out when we talk about
these is that there is this like
flywheel that happens once you become
a certain level of famous
it's almost like uh you know that that
graph that's like going viral the [__]
around and find out graph
is basically like [__] around to find
out but the positive version so you
could kind of like if Oprah was like
here's Oprah's maple syrup here's
Oprah's um you know like new line of
spoons here's Oprah's uh you know new
board game like what does it really
matter at this point it'd be like her
board game does 50 million in sales her
syrup is the number one syrup in the
country right now like it's kind of at
that point you just choose and because
so much trust and distribution has been
built up and I have a friend
who this week I can't say the details
but they went to a very famous person
they went to a very famous person and
they said they had a business idea they
said hey uh our friend has a has a
background in a certain industry and
said hey famous person you should be
doing something in that industry let me
walk to you
show up at your door knock at your door
and say
here's a full business plan of exactly
how you would dominate in this category
so they go they fly out
knock on the door
um first they don't meet the famous
person famous person sends a a manager
to them Senza by the way are they are
they like A-list famous they're super
famous yes super super famous got it
okay A-list famous and so they go to
them and first they get hit with a
manager and they say they're trying to
like look over the manager's head be
like hey is a famous I just wanted to
talk to
just hoping to get a word in with the
famous person can you get out of the way
and they're like no no you have to get
through this wall first they talk to the
manager first they say hey look here's
my background I've been super successful
in this industry I think you guys could
crush it in this industry
um why don't can I meet the famous
person now and tell them the idea they
said no no tell me the idea I'm in
charge of this I said okay here's the
idea and then the person says manager
says that's a good idea okay cool and um
then they get the meeting with the the
famous and the pull time they were told
hey uh you fly in on Monday you'll meet
with the famous person sometime this
week just hang out in the hotel just be
here which is a pretty big time move to
try to pull on somebody to not give you
a time but say hey we'll we'll hold this
walkie-talkie
would you hear me put your pants on get
ready for the meetings happening but I I
can't tell you everything like they've
got a special calendar and Google it
everything ends in ish but it's you know
monday-ish you know like it's all ish
right you're giving a window and you
better be prepared it during that window
to strike okay so end up getting the
meeting with the with the famous person
famous person comes in explain the whole
idea
famous person uh likes the idea but also
has a bunch of their own ideas of course
as famous people do and so I asked my
friend later I said uh so what happened
and uh the response was this they go
well
I'm pretty sure we convinced famous
person that they should do this and do
this with us and I'm pretty sure they
convinced me that I should not do this
with them
I thought that was the hilarious
takeaway and I was like okay well why
they said well you know they have all
their own ideas they go honestly
everything they're trying to do in the
space probably won't work
like I think they're going about it the
whole wrong way
but they'll probably end up being
successful anyways that's the crazy
thing about this like uh their margin
for error is so large and that it can
kind of do anything and still have it
work because their brand their celebrity
their distribution their trust and
loyalty In Their audience is so large
that you can kind of mess up eight out
of ten things and still get it get it to
work eventually
um whereas most startups most businesses
don't have that margin for for error and
so I don't know what the big takeaway is
it's kind of a no dub but it's a
if you're mega mega famous it's not hard
at that point to do the Empire thing
because
uh it's like uh what was his name the
noise from native how he when he was
selling his company and they're like you
sell just deodorant you know you're
asking for this big valuation he goes
yeah because uh do you know how to write
the word native on a bottle of shampoo
do you know how to write the word native
on a on a bottle of toothpaste cool
that's your expansion plan like I left a
lot of room for this to grow if you
could still write the word native on
something it will work and that's that's
how I feel about these Mega celebrity
Brands which is like if you if you put
my face on something it's gonna work
so let's let's put this in in a very
realistic context so you and I have that
minus or no divided by a hundred so
we're Oprah divided by a thousand
whatever it is but we we have a very
small taste of it and we also have
friends you know like the Tim ferrisses
of the world and and whoever else who
have it you know times 10 or 20 for us
and are in this like potentially billion
dollar space
there's been three things I think that
I've narrowed it down to that make this
Empire strategy
um
that whole hold me back and and I
imagine
someone like Tim who's a perfectionist
or someone like that holds them back
number one is reputational risk so
putting your name on crap products and
then how on Earth can you actually like
track it all to make sure that you're
not you're not putting your name on bad
on bad products that you actually Stand
By and so because of that it's almost
like you have to pick and choose but
then there's other people like Richard
Branson that put you know virgin on
everything and it kind of has seemed
like it worked out uh so that's like the
big thing number two is finding people
who you can trust when you have five or
ten or thirty different things going on
you need really trustworthy people and
even if it's your family even if it's
your brother and your cousin people can
screw you and like you have to really
stay on top of it you have to find a
partner who's good enough to like really
have your back like even my accountant
or imagine if like your lawyer your
accountant and every once in a while
you're like is this person actually
thinking of me or how are they
incentivized here and who's actually
making the right decision that's
actually exhausting and I think in in
quite hard
um and then the final thing is like do
they want the headache of that so like a
Joe Rogan uh he's just like no F this
like I'm on my Island here I have what I
need I don't want to put my name on
anything uh screw that I I don't need
anything and I want to keep things small
and tight and so those are kind of the
three things I think prevent like
Empires from being built like this
yeah I think that's true
um so say that say the the first one
again what was the first one do you
remember reputational risk having people
that you can trust and then just like
not wanting more headache and here's the
counter to each okay reputational risk
put your your name on crap products do
you uh have you drank Prime
uh once I tried it it's fine it's fine
it's also the fastest growing drink in
the country right now and it's fine and
I think that that's the the counter to
that is
yes you can't put it on a crap product
or do something that would you know hurt
people or do something like that like
you know nothing nothing on the sort of
terrible end of the register but there's
a lot of leeway between the best product
in the market and it's fine and you just
gotta fall somewhere there right it's
like a it's like you're playing golf and
the Fairway is so wide you really gotta
screw it up if you had to hit it out of
bounds and that's how I feel with these
products like is uh Kylie's lip product
the best product on the market I have no
idea is um you know for most of these
products I can't tell you that Conor
McGregor's whiskey or The Rock's tequila
is uh is anything better than fine they
might just be you're saying their head
there's got to be a threshold there's a
threshold or the threshold's pretty
goddamn low so I think the reputational
risk is is a little bit less than than
what I what I think a lot of people
would worry about uh the rest is true it
can become a headache and you do have to
find competent people to run them the
good thing is when you have that brand
it's like Prime the pro you know Prime
didn't start by Logan Paul and KSI
saying let's create a drink let's go to
the flavor house and create a
formulation
there were some entrepreneurs who
approached them that said we do this
we've done this at you know medium scale
with you guys we could go super scaled
and we will take care of everything you
guys take the cut you guys help us with
the promotion but like look we come with
this track record and I think that's
what happens for most of these these
celebrities as they're approached by
people with track records like even the
example I was just giving somebody with
a track record came and said I know this
industry I've done this before with your
brand and your distribution we could do
this again in a big way
um and I think those opportunities just
come knocking at your door so it's not
even like where do I go find somebody
great it's like can I filter can I just
like recognize great when it shows up
shows up at my door is really the uh the
question for most these people
do you think you would enjoy that type
of Fame like chip and Joanna
no
um Not only would I not enjoy it
from a like oh I don't want to get
bothered when I'm out and about with my
kids and stuff like that but also I more
than that is I don't enjoy what it takes
to get there and that's actually what
goes like that's actually the most
important question of business I was
talking to Ben Levy about this the other
day we're talking about business ideas
earlier earlier I asked you this a while
ago and you go there's a price to pay I
ain't willing to pay it yeah exactly
know the price and then decide if you're
if you're gonna pay it
um when we were talking about business
ideas it was like oh do we like this
idea or this idea and the easy thing to
do I think everybody gets this wrong is
like I love basketball so I want to do a
basketball based idea or I love I'm
really passionate about like helping
people so I'm gonna do this Healthcare
startup whatever it may be and they
think that their enjoyment of the of the
thing is going to be based on the
product or category that they're in but
in reality
most of the time you spend when you're
an entrepreneur is trying to grow or
sell it's trying to get more customers
and grow grow their actual business
and so you're not playing basketball
your day-to-day experience is actually
about selling and trying to grow and
what ends up happening is that some ways
are more enjoyable or suit you better
than others so for some people they love
Facebook ads or they love SEO and for
some people they love phone calls and
for some people they love high-level
business deals Enterprise sales uh where
you're nurturing a long relationship for
a long period of time and the big
mistake people make is they think oh I'm
creating a basketball related startup
what they don't realize is that the only
way for that business to grow is through
Enterprise sales and they hate
Enterprise sales so they're unwilling to
go and sell to these facility managers
of NBA stadiums or they're unwilling to
sell to blah blah blah and they think
they're in the basketball business but
they're in the Enterprise sales business
because ninety percent of their
day-to-day
work and they're they're the challenge
that they're faced with and the the
stuff they have to do
the whether they're selling basketballs
or ping pong balls or uh books it
doesn't matter it's the the sales
channel the sales process is where
you're gonna spend most of your time so
you got to figure out which sales
process do I like the most or at least
tolerate the best and then find a
business that uses that sales process
right I think that is like a
I wish somebody had told me that earlier
because I got tripped up with this for
many many years and when I look back I'm
like oh
I just really like growing things
through Facebook ads it's like it to me
it's way better than these other ones
and so like so I have a list I'm like my
favorite sales channel is just mention
it on the podcast it couldn't be
anything easier than that like if I
could just tell people what I think
about this product and then they go buy
it because they already trust me and
they like me and we have enough
listeners to this product uh to this
podcast that is the number one easiest
sales Channel most pleasurable so if I
can think of a business that works in
that fantastic number two for me is
Facebook ads why because I don't have to
talk to anybody I sit behind the
computer I set up the budget and when it
works I just scale it up with the push
of a button I don't have to hire more
sales people I don't have to like go do
something new you can take one image
that works or one video One 10 second
video that works in Facebook ads and put
millions of dollars of spend behind it
and make multiple Millions more off that
ad I love that I love that model I like
that I can look at the dashboard see a
number and know what to do
I yes that's like my number two and my
number three is cold emails because I'm
good at Cold emailing and it's kind of a
pain in the ass but I've done it before
I can train people to do that I've had a
cold email in order to generate
customers those are my three favorites
everything else I don't like as much and
so when I think of an idea it's got to
fall in that top three
have you so we had I guess technically
the hustle kinda was Enterprise sales I
mean we had six maybe once or twice we
had seven figure deals and that's like a
long process I wasn't allowed to go to
those meetings because like I remember
like I had to go and buy like brown
shoes and like tight jeans and like tuck
my shirt in and like a certain way I was
like dude like I'm Todd nice to meet you
uh like uh it wasn't for me got all the
details wrong just a tank top tucked in
some khakis which are tucked into some
brown shoes yeah
yeah
you're not created everything right
before the meeting they're like Sam that
the buttons are supposed to be in the
front
that was a breakaway
yeah so I was like was learning as I as
I went but as the owner of a company
that had Enterprise sales it is awesome
because what I didn't realize there's
this amazing thing that I learned which
is that sales teams can create demand so
even if your product our product was
great but even if your product is okay
if you have a good sales team you can
truly create demand and I didn't
understand that until like year two or
three of like having a team like this
I'm like oh my God this is how the world
works because most big companies they
just have a certain amount of budget
they have to spend it on something and
if you just get in with them and you
wind and dine them and you they like you
half the time the product doesn't even
matter they just have to spend it
otherwise next year they won't have the
same budget if they don't have the same
budget they don't have a job
so and you can like that or you cannot
like it frankly I don't love that that
that's like the truth but if you can
make it work it's pretty amazing and I
like learned that the hard way while
running a company like this and if you
don't know which one you like your best
bet is to go get exposure to a bunch of
them so go go try your hand and do like
a six month rotation where you're
basically like okay how do I do this
Enterprise sales thing how do I do cold
calling how do I do Google ads how do I
do these different things and figure out
which one of these appeals to you
because once you do that then then you
could kind of pick and choose I know
most most people and I think you you
would find this to be true
most successful people we know they
don't really hop around sales channels
that much it's like no if they're good
at find one thing and you kill it yeah
oh you're good at SEO they just do SEO
four different times of four different
flavors oh you good at Facebook ads you
do Facebook ads for one business then
another business then another business
if you're good at uh Enterprise sales
you just figure out you know which
businesses to plug into that over time
and they kind of make a career out of
really understanding one growth process
because
being a master at any growth thing is uh
is super super valuable
oh
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow better
[Music]
um do you want to talk about hustle GP
GPT 3 or do you want to go to another
topic
um which let's do some quicker ones I
feel like we did a long long-winded
thing so I have I have a couple quick
ones
tell me okay so I'm gonna give you my
two uh bad dating ideas and by the way
I'd like to to put another drunk ideas
on the books to uh to just put that out
there this would have been in my drunk
ideas thing but we don't have it
scheduled so I'm just gonna do it sober
so
um
two bad dating ideas
um number one do you watch this TV show
love is blind
Sarah does so it's on my TV all the time
okay good so you know that you and my
wife have like the exact same TV stuff
like for the listener Sean and Sarah are
texting about Bachelor or Bachelorette
or whatever it's called yeah or no what
do you guys talk about the challenge the
challenge but also these other shows so
um so love is blind is this like
sensation Show on Netflix which is
basically like you get a bunch of single
people together they're in these rooms
they can't see each other so you kind of
speed date you're dating you date other
people but you never get to see them so
you're only supposed to fall over their
personality and then after you choose
who you like the best on their
personality then you get to see them and
you get to see what happens okay so and
don't you like get married at the end
yeah well of course to to like any great
story you need stakes and so they've
raised the stakes by saying you don't
just get to pick say oh I like Sam the
best let me I want to see him now it's
like in order to see him he must get
engaged blind and get married four weeks
later so they like you know that's how
they make it a TV show but some people
walk walk on the altar yeah well a lot
of people when they see the other person
they're like oh
hey it's so good to see you like they're
just like oh man like I imagine
something different and now I'm stuck
with you right now I look like an
[__] because I fell in love with your
personality and I fell out of love with
your face uh but they can't say that so
they have to find some other excuse
one guy on the show was like they're
trying to get an idea of how uh how they
looked and they go so I'm pretty the guy
was like I only weigh 150 pounds yes
could I give you a piggy background he
goes and it was so smooth the way he did
it and vice versa he terrible he goes I
love to go to music festivals she's like
me too he goes at music festivals you
know I uh I usually put my girlfriend up
on my shoulders
um do you think I'd be able to do that
he's like did she catch it yeah she was
like uh like no that's my worst
nightmare is a guy like struggling to
lift my body weight
and so she was just like what the hell
but what size rowboat do we need on this
on this season there's one guy she they
fell in love and then they meet and he's
just he's not he's not bad looking or
whatever but he's does really intense
eye contact like the guy doesn't blink
and she's like you're gonna never known
this from behind the wall and so she's
like haha like how come you're not
looking away and he's like what what do
you mean I am blinking and she's like no
like please look away it's like so
uncomfortable to watch so anyways great
show
I think somebody should take this show
on the road literally I think somebody
should do a I think the show but if not
the show then somebody should spin this
off do a Love is Blind tour where you go
City to city and people pay to be a part
of the experiment so people pay to
actually like do the show themselves I
also think you should do a podcast
version of Love is Blind because podcast
is Audio Only so it's already no visual
so you could have two people talking and
you could sort of edit and cut this
together and make a a pod version of
Love is Blind so I think people could
take this concept of this dating show or
it could be other dating shows too but
make a make a tour out of it make a show
out of it where it's going from City to
city and people get to participate
almost like American Ninja Warrior some
people get to participate and other
people get to watch the the show going
down and uh I think that these things
could generate a lot of money ticket
wise because Netflix has done the hard
work of educating the market and so once
you get that education in the market now
somebody should go to them and get the
license like we talked about this with
uh kids cartoons like or they can just
call it like uh love with poor eyesight
[Laughter]
I forgot my glasses love so so like
people did this with a cartoon that was
a
I gave you a laugh to try to like you
know smooth it over
um but like kids cartoons like blippi or
cocoa melon there's these companies that
go and they license the rights to create
the cocomelon live tour or the blippi
live tour and I've gone to these and
these I did a segment on the Pod about
these these things make millions of
dollars a year yeah well the every
parent loves it's like where you can't
really there's not many places you could
take a tiny kid that's like kid friendly
but this is perfect because they already
love these cartoons on YouTube and so
I'm willing to pay 50 bucks a ticket
times four so I pay 200 bucks then I buy
the merch then I buy the snacks because
of course my kids want snacks and you
know we go there and we've dropped 400
500 by the by the end of it or you know
something like that and so these these
shows can make a lot of money and so I
think somebody could do this with other
television shows including the dating
shows
that's not a bad idea at all
well that's that's a great idea
something worse you should have seen an
average person trying to explain that
idea
you would have laughed in the bathroom
okay here's my second Love is Blind on
tour ah even that sounds all right so my
second uh bad dating uh idea okay so
you've heard about this like dating app
Raya you know about this app
it's basically a dating app originally
for famous people but now it's like
dating apps for people with like
verified on Instagram or something yeah
I don't even really understand it
I think somebody needs to come over the
top on Raya and make the even more Elite
dating app so I'm calling it Daddy
here's what Daddy is
so daddy daddy or daddy you know we're
debating it internally so
daddy is an app where for a guy to be on
Daddy actually let me first start with
the girls side okay for a woman to be on
Daddy she's got a basically audition or
apply and we're only accepting the top
one percent of eligible women so this is
beautiful but not just beautiful
smart but not just smart you got to be
living in a in a town a big city so that
you know you're available to be to be to
be uh you know reached to be dated so
beautiful smart top one percent maybe
even point one percent of applicants get
in more more Elite than Harvard
and then on the guy side
you got to pay 25 000 a year to be on
the app so that's the app idea five
thousand men if you can get five
thousand men who have the money to drop
25 G's on their dating app
they get access to this Elite Pool of
women who want access to this Rich group
of men and it is what it is that's our
slogan it is what it is
is it right nah but it is what it is
okay and so it is what it is it's Rich
guys with beautiful smart women and the
business model is if we can get 5 000
guys to pay us this amount that's a
hundred million dollars a year business
does that sound like something you might
be interested in
[Laughter]
so when I was studying like for Hampton
to launch Hampton I was like curious
about communities and there's a bunch of
a lot of people are like you should
charge like a hundred grand a year and
the reason being is there's a bunch of
communities out there where the whole
thing of making it Elite and Community
is just can you pay the money yes and I
was thinking about that and I'm like
first like the audacity and second if
you can get
my first question is how dare you you
are yeah who are you uh and the but if
you can get past that
how amazing is that where your whole
business is just ah if you could pay it
you're probably good so we'll just uh
we'll we'll be we'll happen to be that
middleman and check it out and so
there's this app called The League do
you know what the league is it's a
dating app it started when we're in San
Francisco about this woman named Amanda
Bradford who I'm friends with here in
Austin
she sold it recently to
what's the big the big company IAC who
owns like match and Bumble and or not
Bumble Tinder and what Amanda was
getting started she was or the the
league kind of took off and so I don't
you probably don't know it was the
premise right it was like only it was
like an Ivy League
but then she one day she was like
how hard can I push this and so right
now the league costs I believe it's
either 499 or 999 dollars so it's either
499 or 999 it's one of those two and the
reason being is that's the highest price
per month that you can charge on Apple's
uh on the Apple Store 399 per month
sorry yeah 399 dollars per month
so yeah it's it's the highest that you
could possibly charge and she goes screw
it that's what it's going to cost to get
premium features and people like at our
I think her team was like this is crazy
we can't do this no one will do this and
it crushed it an IAC came to her and
they're like we want to buy you because
how on Earth are you able to charge this
and I imagine in her head she was like
well it was actually pretty easy I just
uh added an extra nine at the end
actually you're right nine the highest
tier is called investor uh member 299
owner 399 investor
999.99 yeah yeah yeah it's like uh it's
like uh there's like an episode in South
Park where they come up with this like
new MBA and they're like look I don't
make up the rules I just think them up
and write them down you can't argue with
me I didn't make up the rules and it's
like well how'd you increase pricing so
much well I just clicked that button
nine and uh we added we made it instead
of 999 we made it 900 or instead of
99.99 it was 999 so anyway it's killed
it and so I actually think that there
are a lot of interesting opportunities
in the market where you can just charge
way more and it feels very weird that's
the business model and actually now that
I think about it twenty five thousand
dollars a year that was complete small
boy stuff and I apologize to the entire
audience
this needs to be 100 Grand a year this
has to be 100 Grand a year and guess
what we only need a thousand members now
we only need a thousand guys who are
willing to drop 100 Grand in order to
get access to the most and in fact you
know what we're gonna do we're gonna
take a portion of that money and we're
gonna pay some women to be on this app
we're gonna say look you are so great
you were casted onto this and you are
going to be paid to be a part of this
network because
um we want to blur the lines between
prostitution and legal dating oh my God
it is what it is as we say
God bless you maybe this will work but
yeah good but I think there's there
needs to be more uh apps that do this
that go over the top uh with it like I
agree basically find the theoretical Max
of uh of of what what the market will
bear or what uh what people actually
want to do right like what what is the
actual Behavior people want and what are
they willing to do and it's usually more
than you think
um or more than you know sound sounds
reasonable like what what if you just
took an unreasonable approach to the
same thing what would you do differently
is it is a question you can ask about
really any business
like there's these guys that created
this thing called the unreasonable
Institute back in the day and I loved Is
that real yeah it was a great it was a
great idea is it called the unreasonable
Institute and it was for I just love the
name because I loved the entire premise
which was
what good has been come from just taking
a reasonable approach to something if
you're trying to make any big [__]
happen you're trying to do anything
change the way anything works you know
like create a new system or improve
something or innovate
you know in a way by definition you're
going to do something slightly
unreasonable
um and so is this called the
unreasonable group yeah it was called
the unreasonable Institute then they had
the unreasonable like toward where they
like
they like on a cruise ship and went into
international waters
um and then they did a bunch of this now
it's probably called this is like 10
plus years ago so yeah that's so funny
that's probably true well there's a
thing called unreasonable group and it's
the unreasonable Collective is an
International Community of sophisticated
investors we pull we pull Capital as a
community and co-invest in world class
but then there's the unreasonable
Institute which is a fast track program
to give altruistic entrepreneur skills
and funding to affect large-scale change
yeah I think that's the one sounds maybe
a little yeah the first one maybe sounds
cooler though but uh uh that's cool I
like that name
um speaking of unreasonable you want to
wrap this up by talking one thing Elon
Musk okay did you see what he did uh so
you see the Twitter thing
well which which sort of thing I feel
like every day there's a Elon Musk
Twitter thing yeah that's
where he blurred out the W oh yeah oh
okay this is news no no I saw this so
basically this is to explain this this
is dumb there's this there's this thing
in the UFC call if you win so basically
the UFC and all but fighting it has
weight divisions and every once in a
while someone like Conor McGregor or
someone else comes along and they
achieve greatness and they earn what's
called The Champ champ status meaning
they have a champ uh they're the
champion in one weight Division and then
while having that belt they also gain a
few pounds and go up and win another
belt it's unheard of in my opinion Elon
is the champ champ he has amazing
products he's one of the best
entrepreneurs out there he's the
champion he's also the most cringiest
he's the champ champ right now uh he
does whatever the [__] he wants that's
what champ Champs do and recently like
last night he tweeted out that there was
a dispute with the landlord saying you
can't like alter the sign or something
like that so he took like a piece of
white sheet or paper or something and he
blurred out the W so now Twitter the
sign it's a huge sign when you live in
San Francisco I lived a block away from
it it says titter
and it's the most cringed thing I've
ever seen why on Earth would he do that
I love a good troll but that's not like
funny it just makes like people like
look I like trolling I love punching up
uh but this is like uh this is punching
yourself in the face I like making
people uncomfortable this is the bad
type of uncomfortable
go to his Twitter uh right now do you
see what his name is on Twitter right
now because you thought that was the
cringiest thing he's done in the last 48
hours well
he's one-upped himself oh my God what an
idiot oh God what is his Twitter name
his name right now is hey hairy balls he
spells balls
b-o-l-z but it's hairy balls that is his
name on Twitter right now oh Elon you're
so you're so irreverent
yeah dude
these Billionaire's senses of humor
just like us I would love to see what
Elon thinks the like other people's
reaction is he must type these in and
just sit back and just smirk just have a
smug look on his face just imagine oh
man
the internet's gonna love this
I I'm super rich but I don't take myself
too seriously look at this yeah next
week it's gonna be like uh like Elon
baller 69. like it's just like
this is the lamest thing ever man I
don't know how I mean I guess like look
with extreme personalities comes to
extreme success but they don't tell you
there's another end of that bell curve
and that's extreme that's extreme cringe
and that and we're experiencing that a
little bit right now I know a lot of
billionaires not a lot I know a couple
billionaires and I know a lot of wildly
successful people and they do every once
in a while like you're like oh hey man
you don't know how to hold a
conversation appropriately let me help
you out here this is kind of what's
happening with him it just so happens
that it's in front of 125 million
followers he has like the cringe version
of Tourette's like dude just stop you
can't he can't stop just blurting out
these cringy things yeah it's it's
ridiculous
um he's he I actually think that he's
kind of ruining his legacy for sure here
um like maybe five years ago he was the
man
um and he still is the man frankly like
his accomplishments are amazing but he's
a little less of the man at this point
it was a funny just a little funny back
and forth he uh somebody tweeted out a
um a graph of all the billion dollar
chart of all the billion dollar
companies and what industries they're in
yeah I saw that and uh Paul Graham
retweeted and he says oh you know what's
interesting here is like
we're clearly like over indexed online
software and like you know real world
things like uh Hardware or manufacturing
you know there's only like a few
companies in that bucket
um but don't let that hold you back you
should still do it I think there's a lot
of opportunity there and Elon replied
and was like um
yeah like a complete waste uh you know
it says something like it was like a big
waste of um of resources or brain power
or talent that that was the case
and then uh and the the response was the
biggest own and I've seen in a week it
was it was a really good reply program
goes yeah can you think of anybody right
now who's really talented and uh it
could be doing those things but is
wasting their time on a software project
and it's so good because obviously talk
about Elon
um and uh yeah it's like a perfect self
cell phone really by Elon yeah it was
pretty good
[Laughter]
took it it was good that was good I'm a
big fan of him
um of Paul Grant I'm still an Elon guy I
think I might get myself a Tesla but
I don't like this it makes it hard to
want to wear like a Tesla t-shirt that's
for sure not that he cares but uh it
makes it challenging to like root for
him publicly when he makes these stupid
comments people people in our comments
hate when I make fun of uh Elon or or
dis Elon or chamoth or these guys uh
because they're like fans of them which
is totally fair you could be fans of
whoever you want uh but I just wanted
for the record
I'm out on Elon early
because guess what more and more you're
gonna be out on this guy over time and I
just want to plant the flag
I'm out on him early because his cringe
will eventually wash away all these
people or he's gonna get canceled for
something I'm telling you it's it's
gonna happen and I I would like the
record to show that I was out early
dude these these people in our comments
are crazy to me because why can't
someone do a lot of really good stuff
and also some bad stuff like why can't
like someone kick ass at a at a ton of
different things and make a huge amount
of mistakes totally uh because whenever
we talk about this we say yeah he's he's
the best at a bunch of different things
he's the greatest entrepreneur he's of
of I don't know the last 30 years 50
years that is true also true
he's pretty cringe and uh Courtney
and disingenuous amounts of some things
right that's also true
yeah it's like I can love Michael
Jackson's music and also not love what
he did you know like both like both can
exist I can like Chick-fil-A chicken and
also not stand by what they right what
they stand for you know both can be true
and I and I can't stand that with the
with the commenters on our on our stuff
but let's we're gonna get a reaction on
this I'm eager to see what it is but uh
anyway that's an action-packed pod I
think
[Music]